Oh Oh I'm turned on by both we wanted to
conduct an experiment here in this
beautiful bar where we could actually
put perceived masculinity to the test so
what you'll see is our wonderful subject
Broderick we're training two different
versions of himself one that tends to do
so much more traditionally masculine and
how he conducts himself the guy on the
right didn't smile so I feel like you
have this inclination where you want to
win him over people like the chase I
would [ __ ] the guy on the right I would
probably be in a relationship with a guy
on the left and the other one where he
tends to be less so and can show a very
different side of himself I feel he's
more approachable could be gay to
determine if people do tend to be a
little bit more attracted to the
traditionally masculine traits you can
kind of show a lot about ourselves based
on how much or how little we're smiling
people tend to say that they're really
attracted to the bad boy which is a
little bit more of a smolder this guy on
the right would let me have it like yeah
I'm gonna give it to you hard and then
guys like sweet like we can have a good
giggle this experiment is actually
really interesting because it's not
about the differences between masculine
or feminine but how we're valuing that
you can take the test as it's going
along and see what comes up for you
oh I think I hate both of them now I'm
into the one on the right dude Oh got
manspreading was that I am NOT so you're
not I like the guy on the left now the
way that he's sitting up his clothing
this guy might be too proper for me he
seems a little more at ease so I'm more
inclined to go with the right someone
might try to order a drink and the
census guys spread out they can't get to
him to me and then the right I like more
because I love sweatpants I enjoy a good
penis print more of a relaxed look and
presentation based on how we're dressed
and how we're positioned tends to be a
little bit more traditionally masculine
because it shows that there's not been
too much thoughtfulness or effort that's
been placed and
the guy on the left is real at the
action I can tell that he's a little bit
more effeminate in his gestures but I
find that kind of sexy here a good buddy
or not the type of person that I want to
take home with I think I know what
firework looks like his body language
reads a lot friendlier than the other
guy it was easier to just focus on mr.
right because he was just staring at you
I need that game that like are you Jimmy
aren't you like that's what it places me
and gestures I tend to use a lot of hand
gestures from one version of Broderick
you'll see him using his hands a lot
more and that tends to be less
traditionally masculine because it's
opening up a little bit more like an
emotional vulnerability did you see that
shot though dude that thing was crazy
the whole apartments that I go Bobby
wait did you see that shot last night
dude that thing was crazy man the whole
apartment was deep I get the
juxtaposition but that was too slow he
was able to just say something and it
mattered I always wished that I had that
smooth voice look just like my channel
just my iron I think I would be drawn to
find the person with a lower voice than
like the guy with the high squeaky voice
how come I grew up with men that were
very much Eastman I see myself being
attracted to that Beach you can
communicate a lot being slower or lower
is something that tends to be a little
bit more traditionally masculine because
it doesn't really show an openness
I mean definitely on the right yeah he's
way more engaged so you find yourself
really drawn to the one that's gonna be
like Al actin hell yeah he's leaning in
a little bit that's what endearing he
looked like he was actually paying
attention and cared what do you hate
about the guy he's just looking at other
people don't make eye contact don't look
at bad so just that little snippet is
like oh that sexy eye contact really
conveys a lot of intimacy because when
you're looking directly at somebody's
eyes it's kind of like looking into the
window of their souls so there can be an
emotional connection from that so what
happened between you and your ex well I
always felt like I was the one loving
her and caring for her and everything
but it seems like she wasn't happy she
always felt like she was the one that
was calling the shots and always doing
everything right and she basically broke
my heart well I mean we tried to make it
work we went out a lot we tried to do
different things we tried to you know
find the missing pieces but
unfortunately we just couldn't figure it
out there's like Nicholas Sparks up in
here I think the left was a little bit
of a turn-off because he kept blaming
her I was ready to be like but her he
just had the answers too quickly you
can't closure there the one on the right
there was a lot of ambiguity I was like
just spit it out he was very like
internalized about it and just seemed
like he was still thinking about it in
his head he's not over her because he's
still saying we-we-we where's number one
with like I I I so emotional
intelligence or EQ is when you have just
a deeper awareness and insight about the
emotional temperature of whatever might
be going on we can typically think about
how traditionally a man is supposed to
be really aggressive and kind of
forthcoming otherwise it's showing an
emotional awareness so when
honey I'm free Wednesday are you free
I'm free after 6:00
I'm sure sex is good don't you know I
know this really don't tie your
restaurant down yeah and yes you know
really okay so Wow yeah no way on the
right I'd rather have like an exact plan
and footprint it just makes you feel
like the person cares about you so it's
like yeah well whatever we'll figure it
out and that means that I'm never gonna
see you again yeah I feel like I'm such
a [ __ ] so if I pick the one on the right
maybe I'm a flake
I don't know pressure freaked me out it
was small so there's something cool
about it commitment tends to be
something where we can tell a little bit
about a person and traditionally
speaking a man isn't supposed to be as
committed or available it's kind of what
you think of as like the aloof guy
what's attractive about that what is it
that's something deeper like ruder than
me where I'm like vying for someone's
attention all right like I don't know
that's [ __ ] up man I don't know I
definitely think that gender norms still
actually influenced though I do think
that there's been an evolution overall
in terms of what that might mean and how
things have been redefined some of us
really exist more emotional sides and
busts existence so much more of a
rational side and it feels like that
those are two competing forces and when
we're guided by what society tells us is
okay and normal then we're gonna be
shifted to one end of the spectrum
instead of being able to have a more
realize sense of ourselves is balanced
overall nipples play good let it breathe
so I enjoy when men let it breathe - and
they
really happy